etc it is important that we should
finally hear the words of apology come
from Kiev and the leaf for the massacre
in the Boeing and it is equally
important that we should be conscious
important of the fact that force however
commanded by Soviet agents murdered
Ukrainians in Poland and conducted the
operation Vistula it is also important
for us to recognize that the leaf was
just a beautiful polish city and that
there is nothing prom in cherishing the
memory of false who died defending
defending it also by those who may
hopefully one day stand to make the town
the intellectual and political center of
ukrainian patriotism the willingness to
cooperate in the future will help us
reflect on the past and forgive the
scenes they should be for the best the
VAT undertake things behind the odessa
brought the prods pipeline and the
buyout of footage and stuff over to the
donbass industrial complex treated as a
past frittata have a common denominator
in form of the russian hand making the
pipe and operational with the transport
of the caspian oil is perceived by the
Russians as contradictory to their
interest and so they do everything
possible to block the project and the
sidelines of privatizing deploy still
works through the bite of the doanburs
consortium confession are the ones to
gain back ties between Ukrainian company
and among others the Russian gospel the
strategic constant between tears and
walls or concerning the containment of
Russian influences in our countries
could lay the foundation for the
national evaluation of the boss projects
the dongers and Russell complex also a
large business entity is not the only
enterprise in Ukraine which might want
to invest in Poland it's a certain that
with
a degree of goodwill partners which do
not rise and adults can be found and as
such will be met with friendly welcome
and Poland as representing the best on
the Ukrainian economic independence by
the by the way this is not for the
international financial institution
institution to judge it this reference
to the most current event and disputes
between our countries should illustrate
well the tease is that it is principally
division and the common understanding of
the goal that we need practical
realization of joint under paintings
will that be significantly less training
and the decisions taken will Nessus will
necessarily be better understood by the
public opinion boss in ukraine's as well
as me poland thank you very much for
this a bit too long
welcome for the question these comments
totally thanks but a question for both
of you please about domestic politics
mr. cutter ship would you comment or
even favorites with a prediction about
at the end of the year and we're we're
cool and that parliamentary changes they
might happen how they were would affect
integration and mr. lane's the excellent
discussion
could you say something about the this
SLG split evidently and i just recently
heard of this time varying the city if
you would and what that will need
particularly in both these situations
the short term implications with the SLV
that is especially the implications of
gardening relations
well as to the the election the outcome
of a predilection presidential elections
in Ukraine this coming to the 31st the
short answer